le rassemblement national miser sur une
victoire dans le canton de bonnières sur
seine
mais c'est finalement le binôme patrick
stefanini et josette gens du groupe
ensemble pour les yvelines qui remporte
ces élections largement en tête avec 70
points 85 % des voix contre seulement 29
15 % des voix pour le binôme rn laurent
maurin et monique fureur moguérou on
écoute la réaction des vainqueurs on est
satisfaits forcément on a beaucoup
travaillé les résultats sont bons pour
nous c'est fantastique
dans le canton
non seulement nous gagnons mais nous
améliorons le score de 2015 pratiquement
2 7 points
alors ça s'inscrit dans une tendance
nationale
ça s'inscrit aussi dans une tendance qui
était qu'ils puissent lire dans les
résultats du premier tour sur le canton
de bonnières mais encore fallait-il
transformer l'essai 82% à houdan 65% à
freneuse et 60% à bonnières sur seine
dans quasiment chaque grande ville du
canton
la liste ensemble pour les yvelines
arrive en tête il n'y a qu'à flacourt
que le duo est reine arrive premier avec
53 70 % des voix même dans les villages
où le parti de marine le pen est
normalement favori le rassemblement
national ne convainc plus une défaite
expliqué par le candidat est reine du
canton de menthe cyril note
ce scrutin a été marqué par une
abstention très forte dont nous avons
été particulièrement victimes donc
effectivement il est très difficile à
mon sens d'en tirer des enseignements et
des duels et y est reine des yvelines
ont donc tous deux été remportées par la
droite ce n'est pas une surprise pour
patrick stefanini la droite républicaine
lorsqu'elle travail lorsqu'elle fait
campagne de manière sérieuse lorsqu'elle
s'appuie sur des candidats qui ont à la
fois de l'expérience de la compétence et
qui parle aux électeurs de leurs
problèmes et bien la droite fait reculer
l'extrême droite
le taux d'abstention s'élève à 63 61 %
pour le canton de bonnières sur seine